für 3000 menschen war das moria camp
ursprünglich angelegt jetzt leben hier
20.000 asylsuchende
sie hausen in notdürftig
zusammengeflickt in zelten jenseits des
offiziellen lagers im sogenannten
dschungel mehr als 1000 menschen teilen
sich einen wasseranschluss und immer
wieder funktioniert auch der nicht oft
kommen wir hier an und es gibt kein
wasser
dann müssen wir ohne wieder nach hause
gehen das ist unser tägliches leben
der afghanische arzt sah da lebt in
einem kleinen zelt zusammen mit seiner
frau und seinen vier kindern
sie flohen vor dem krieg in ihrem land
und sind jetzt auf hilfe angewiesen
das bedeutet auch schlange stehen bei
der essensausgabe stundenlang dicht
gedrängt abstand halten ist in moria
kaum möglich hilfsorganisationen halten
das camp für eine ideale brutstätte für
das corona views roja extremely
konstante war diesen sehr besorgt es ist
sehr eng in dem lager es gibt keine
seife hygiene gibt es quasi überhaupt
nicht und das ist besorgniserregend denn
das heißt dass man eigentlich nichts
machen kann um das virus zu stoppen wenn
es einmal im camp ist die
hilfsorganisation ärzte ohne grenzen
betreibt hier am rande des camps ein
hospital
es gibt kaum corona testkits und längst
nicht genügend ärzte
viele patienten haben bereits
atemwegserkrankungen und sind geschwächt
und damit besonders anfällig für das
chaos
viele menschen sind extrem verwundbar
wir haben viele sehr kranke kinder dort
die an chronischen krankheiten wie
epilepsie oder diabetes andere haben
ernste psychische probleme und wir haben
viele traumatisierte erwachsen all diese
menschen sind sehr anfällig für diese
neue bedrohung ihrer gesundheit die
griechische regierung sagt man sei auf
diese bedrohung vorbereitet und es gäbe
einen chor
ein notfallplan doch den haben die
hilfsorganisationen in moria noch nicht
zu gesicht bekommen
deshalb setzen sie auf selbsthilfe bei
der kleinen ngo team humanity
geflüchtete jetzt atemschutzmasken 300
schaffen sie an einem tag bei uns diese
freiwilligen sind großartig die frauen
setzen hier von 7 uhr morgens bis neun
uhr abends sie wollen helfen
sie sagen ihnen macht doch mal eine
pause aber sie wollen nicht sie wollen
helfen weil sie wissen wie gefährlich
das virus ist jeder weiß um die extreme
gefahr
ich denke in dieser krise kann es nur
eine lösung geben die europäische union
muss jetzt alles nur mögliche tun um
diese menschen so schnell wie möglich zu
evakuieren das markant auf lesbos ist
kein ort an die bank oder bekämpfen kann
es muss jetzt gehandelt werden doch die
europäischen länder schotten ihre
nationalen grenzen weiter ab viele
flüchtlinge haben deswegen angst dass
sie in der korona krise vergessen werden
und europa sie einmal mehr ihrem
schicksal überlässt